so um any of you guys want to play
rocket League against the devs
[Music]
oh yeah we lost one hey guys so Chris
Chris Cohn and Dave are you ready yeah
I'm ready super ready okay this one's
for Jake cool here we go
got that go I got it it's coming back in
the middle Center I got it I got it
Dave's got it
it's drop it's not a good what are you
doing
oh it's not a good look well you got
that
we talked about this Haruko 20 gather go
with the fundamental right communicate
communicate the D you lost your D we
need to get it back dang it knows a
warm-up gig right that was a warm-up
game save nice rebound do not auto goals
do not put it in front
it was going wide
I know coaches get angry all right
backwards
that was a shame this got really good
Pinot toast
I know we've been letting you down here
you do now more than we've ever needed
you before we need a secret play yes I
got it
the new plan is look lag and [ __ ]
I can't get that Oh
so then they adjusted for that tip it
Terk Oh bleep will you hit the ball I
was blocking it you are lying sedate me
next
we are all tied up do you understand
what chance we have here come on guys do
it for me
at least it was the other team that
pushed you out of the way for dead it
you guys suck
shall I write down choke is one of our
options don't choke me coach oh you know
you know what I think
all right let's there's been a lot of
yelling going on I just feel like this
whole operation was a breakdown in
coaching don't you guys I'm out here
that's a good series so I'll tell you
what guys if you want you could take a
month off and do some training and come
back and challenge us again